[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Wulf schmiese guten Abend
Papst franziskus hat um Beistand für
seinen sehr kranken Vorgänger Benedikt
den 16 Gebieten so lautete die erste
Meldung heute sie kamen um 10 Uhr von
der katholischen Nachrichtenagentur und
seitdem scheint klar der einstige
deutsche Papst Josef Ratzinger
inzwischen 95 Jahre alt liegt im Sterben
er hat bereits vor zehn Jahren aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen abgedankt
unsere Italien Korrespondentin Annette
hilfenberg ist auf dem Petersplatz in
Rom Annette was gibt es dort an
aktuellen Informationen
den letzten Hinweis den es gab kam von
Papst franziskus selbst er war ja nach
der Generalaudienz ins Kloster mexail
Serie Gefahren matrixelsi gefahren und
hatte dort Benedikt besucht danach hatte
er auf Twitter dazu aufgefordert für den
emeritierten Papst zu beten und ihn bis
zum Ende zu begleiten der Pressesprecher
des Heiligen Stuhls hatte am Mittag
davon gesprochen dass der
Gesundheitszustand des 95-jährigen in
den Stunden zuvor sich noch mal sehr
verschlechtert habe und der Zustand sei
inzwischen stabil er werde medizinisch
überwacht aber Tatsache ist dass es
schon während der Weihnachtstage so
berichtet ist die italienische
Nachrichtenagentur ansah zu
Atemproblemen bei Benedikt gekommen war
also zu einer Verschlechterung seine
Gesamtzustandes in den letzten Wochen
waren auch auf den Bildern die von
Benedikt in z.B auf sozialen Medien zu
sehen waren
körperlich sehr zerbrechlich wirkender
emritierter Papst zu sehen und welche
Vorbereitungen werden denn jetzt
getroffen für das Ableben eines
emeritierten Papstes im Unterschied zu
einem der noch im Amt war
naja der Fall eines emeritierten Papstes
den hat es ja seit dem Jahr 1415 hier
nicht gegeben und der Vatikan hat dazu
bisher auch nichts bekannt gegeben also
welche Rituale dann durchgeführt werden
da es sich um ein ehemaliges
oberhauptmann Staatsoberhaupt handelt
werden sicherlich Delegationen
internationaler Staaten anreisen und
Benedikt wird sicherlich auch aufgebaut
werden so wie es bei Päpsten üblich ist
er selbst hat auch sein
geistiges Testament bereits geschrieben
und verfügt dass es nach seinem Tod
veröffentlicht geöffnet und
veröffentlicht werden soll und er hat
auch festgelegt seine wo seine letzte
Ruhestätte sein sollen nämlich in der
Krypta das Petersdomes in der in dem
früheren Grab von Papst Johannes Paul
dem zweiten dessen Urne mit den
sterblichen Überresten war in die
Basilika gegangen nach der seiner
Heiligsprechung
vielen Dank Annette hilsenbeck nach Rom
eigentlich sollte es keine Überraschung
sein dass die Taliban radikal ist sind
so radikal dass sie Frauen Bildung und
Arbeit verwehren doch nun scheint die
westliche Welt überrascht über das
Handeln dieser wohl
fundamentalistischsten Regierung
weltweit
vor anderthalb Jahren als die
kriegsmüden Amerikaner und ihre
Verbündeten Hals über Kopf das Land
verließen da versuchen Afghanen vor den
Taliban zu fliehen doch trotz solcher
Bilder sagten Diplomaten noch die
Taliban hätten sich verändert sie
wollten keine internationale Isolation
von wegen nun treiben die Taliban ihren
Frauen und man muss sagen
mädchenverachtenden Islamismus so weit
dass selbst die Hilfsorganisation nicht
mehr weitermachen können oder wollen
kamransafjari an berichtet
Fahrt durch eine Stadt in der Frauen
kein Gesicht haben carbul Afghanistan
wenn man Frauen sieht dann nur so auch
in öffentlichen Parks haben sie keinen
Zutritt
nur an einem versteckten Ort trauen sie
sich ihren Frust heraus zu schreien
Bildung ist unser Recht
wir treffen kirishman ayubi sie studiert
informatigen Kabul das Studium war für
sie der letzte Bereich in dem sie
unabhängig sein konnte
ich bin am Boden zerstört die
Universität war meine ganze Hoffnung ich
wollte studieren mein Uni-Abschluss
machen alle meine Träume sind jetzt
zerplatzt und ich weiß nicht was mit mir
jetzt passiert
der Direktor einer Privatuniversität
zeigt sein lehrgefegtes Klassenzimmer
und erzählt dass die Jungs aus
Solidarität zu den Mädchen den
Unterricht boykottieren
sehen sie so sieht das heutige
Afghanistan aus keine Studenten
Arbeitslose Lehrer wir wissen nicht was
wir tun sollen wer weiß was uns in
Zukunft noch zustoßen wird
keine Rechte für Frauen so das Ziel der
Taliban Mädchen dürfen ab der 6 Klasse
nicht zur Schule auch das Studieren ist
Frauen untersagt jetzt haben die Taliban
an Arbeitsverbot für Frauen in nicht
Regierungsorganisation erlassen eine
Katastrophe für ein Land in dem 28
Millionen Menschen auf humanitäre Hilfe
angewiesen sind Ausnahmen
wir wollen für die Vereinten Nationen
und für den Gesundheitsbereich gelten
als Reaktion haben einige NGOs ihre
Arbeit ausgesetzt ein Dilemma auf der
einen Seite trifft unsere Entscheidung
direkt die die Hilfsbedürftigen hier
aber auf der anderen Seite müssen wir um
vernünftige hilfeleisten zu können
Zugang zu Frauen haben bei Frauen die
betroffensten Menschen hier sind und wir
müssen Zugang zu Frauen haben wir müssen
mit Frauen reden können das geht in
diesem Land nur durch Frauen die bei uns
arbeiten die Taliban wollen das
Afghanistan einen Staat nach Scharia
gesätzen machen ein richtungskampf
zwischen Hardlinern und Pragmatikern
viel zur Außenminister standig Seif eher
gemäßigt gegen den Taliban Führer auch
und würde ein radikal sie scheinen sich
in der Frauenfrage durchgesetzt zu haben
der Westen hat sich in den Taliban
getäuscht so Experten
absehbar das weitere Einschnitte kommen
das ist jetzt so drastisch kommt das ist
natürlich sehr sehr enttäuschend und vor
allem ist es ein ganz klarer Wort und
Vertrauensbruch der Taliban Führung und
da denke ich das darf man so nicht
durchgehen lassen und da muss man jetzt
auch klare Signale senden als Reaktion
hat das Bundesentwicklungsministerium
Projekte der Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
auf Eis gelegt der UN-Sicherheitsrat
fordert die Taliban heute dringend auf
die Frauenrechte zu achten
wir sind nun in Kabul verbunden mit
einem Entwicklungshelfer der Afghanistan
kennt wie wenige denn er hat dort seit
den 90ern immer wieder gelebt und
leitete seit fast einem Jahrzehnt die
Vertretung von Caritas international
guten Abend Stefan Recker nach Kabul
guten Abend Herr schmiese hallo dass die
Taliban eine radikale Regierung sind das
ist ja so neu nicht schon gar nicht für
Sie aus welchen konkreten Anlass haben
sie ihre Arbeit als Hilfsorganisation
nun unterbrochen
am 24 Dezember kam ein Erlass des
Wirtschaftsministerium heraus das
Wirtschaftsministerium hier ist für die
Hilfsorganisation verantwortlich dass
Frauen verboten wurde bei den
Hilfsorganisationen zu arbeiten das
haben wir zum Anlass genommen die
Arbeiten zu unterbrechen zu unterbrechen
heißt ja nicht einstellen also was
können sie derzeit noch leisten und wo
haben sie die Arbeit eingestellt ganz
konkret
von unseren zehn Hilfsprojekten hier in
Afghanistan können drei weiterlaufen das
sind medizinische Projekte ein
literaturberkulose Projekt ein
behindertenprojekt und ein
mutter-kind-gesundheitsprojekt diese
Projekte sind von diesem Erlass nicht
betroffen da im medizinischen Bereich
weiter Frauen arbeiten dürfen die
anderen Hilfsprojekte Verteilungen von
Geld von Winterhilfe von Nahrungsmitteln
sind unterbrochen und wir werden sie
jederzeit wieder aufnehmen wenn die Lage
entsprechend ist das heißt wir wollen
Druck ausüben aber jetzt wird von zig
Millionen Menschen wahrscheinlich in
Afghanistan das Leben noch schlechter
werden von Menschen die er selbst unter
den Taliban leiden und das nehmen Sie
jetzt gelingt den Kauf
nein
das ist ein ein Balanceakt also ich tue
mich da auch sehr sehr schwer und ich
denke die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
den anderen Hilfsorganisationen die ihre
Arbeit jedenfalls unterbrochen haben tun
sich mindestens genauso schwer damit wie
gesagt das ist ein Balanceakt wir müssen
abwägen wo unsere roten Linien sind wir
müssen abwägen was das beste Interesse
der lebensbedürftigen ist und wir sehen
das momentan so dass wir die Arbeit
unterbrochen haben weil ihr einfach
mangelt der Kolleginnen keinen Zugang zu
weiblichen hilfsempfängern haben und
deswegen haben wir die Arbeit offiziell
unterbrochen nun kennen Sie ja die
Taliban seit der ersten Generation seit
Mitte der 90er Jahre kann man denn mit
den Taliban verlässlich verhandeln kann
man Druck ausüben kann man sich
einmischen offenbar fürchten die ja die
Isolation nicht sonderlich
nehmen also in der Tat habe ich schon
unter Taliban 10 in den 90er Jahren
gearbeitet es gibt ein wesentlichen
Unterschied Taliban 1:0 waren eine sehr
homogene Truppe jetzt ist das ist in die
Taliban sehr heterogen es gibt
verschiedene Fraktionen eine immer
robuster auftretend als andere immer
radikaler als andere ich denke momentan
haben die radikaleren Fraktionen das
sagen man kann natürlich mit den Taliban
verhandeln ich selber verhandeln nicht
mit den Taliban das machen andere hier
das z.B die Vereinten Nationen oder eine
NGO schirmorganisation wir stehen da
natürlich beratend und auch fordernd zur
Seite aber dir selber verhandeln nicht
über
haben denn die Moderatoren bei den
Taliban noch Chancen sich durchzusetzen
also momentan sehe ich das nicht also
die
Hardcore Taliban haben momentan das
sagen die fundamentalistische
radikaleren talibanen momentan das sagen
ich denke das auch eine der Gründe für
diesen Erlass von 24 Dezember
vielen dank Stefan Recker und gute
Wünsche für 2023 Ihnen nach Kabul
vielen Dank auf Wiedersehen
und in Afghanistan geht es nun bereits
auf halb zwei nachts zu und deswegen
haben wir am frühen Abend gesprochen und
morgen wollen übrigens andere
Hilfsorganisationen wie care and save
the Children bekannt geben wie es für
sie weitergeht und mit weiteren
Spannungen und zwar in unserer
europäischen Nachbarschaft da beginnen
nun die Nachrichten mit Hanna Zimmermann
mit Blick auf den Konflikt zwischen
Serbien und dem Kosovo hat die
Bundesregierung sich sehr besorgt
gezeigt die Entscheidung Serbien seine
Militärpräsenz nahe der Grenze zum
Kosovo hochzufahren setze ein völlig
falsches Signal erklärte ein Sprecher
des Außenministeriums unterdessen hat
das Kosovo heute den größten
Grenzübergang nach Serbien gesperrt
zuvor hatten Serben im Kosovo
Straßenblockaden errichtet Hintergrund
der Spannung ist die Tatsache dass
Serbien die Unabhängigkeit des Kosovo
seit Jahren nicht anerkennt
zur Lage in der Ukraine wo es auch heute
wieder Luftangriffe gegeben hat
besonders davon betroffen waren die
südukrainische Stadt Croissant laut
ukrainischen Angaben hat die russische
Armee die kürzlich von der Ukraine
zurückeroberte Stadt mit Artillerie und
33 raketenbeschossen dabei sei auch eine
Geburtsklinik getroffen worden
in der Türkei hat ein Berufungsgericht
die lebenslange Haftstrafe für den
Kulturförderer Osman Kavala bestätigt
das im April gefällt die Urteil sei
rechtmäßig gewesen entschied das Gericht
in Istanbul die Verurteilung kavalas
hatte international Schafe Kritik
hervorgerufen auch aus Deutschland aber
das Verteidigung bleibt nun noch die
Möglichkeit vor dem Obersten Gerichtshof
der Türkei gegen das Urteil vorzugehen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck hat
erklärt dass er noch bis Ende 2023 mit
höheren Gaspreisen rechnet und das
obwohl diese an den Großhandelsmärkten
zuletzt gesunken sind der Preis für
europäisches Erdgas viel heute zeitweise
auf den tiefsten Stand seit Beginn des
Ukraine Kriegs und lag bei rund 76 Euro
je Megawattstunde das Rekordhoch in
diesem Jahr betrug 347 Euro zu den
Gründen zählen die milden Temperaturen
durch die weniger geheizt werden musste
zudem wurde viel Windenergie erzeugt
und wir machen weiter mit Energie das
hier ist ein Lebenszeichen die Fackel
von Schwedt und solange das Feuer dort
brennt dort oben dann wird in der
brandenburgischen Stadt Benzin und
Heizöl hergestellt und zwar für
Brandenburg und Berlin und seit knapp 60
Jahren lodert diese Flamme weil immer
russisches Rohöl kam ins petrol
chemische Kombinat Schwedt nun Pck
in vier Tagen ist Schluss damit mit dem
russischen Rohöl im September hat
Deutschland Russland zum Jahresende
wegen des Überfalls auf die Ukraine
gekündigt und nun verweigert auch
Russland die Lieferung Jan Meyer blickt
ins neue Jahr von Schwedt die
Beschäftigten des PCK haben in diesen
Tagen besonders viel zu tun um den
Betrieb ohne Erdöl aus Russland
vorzubereiten groß sind dabei ihre
Sorgen um die Zukunft teilweise haben
wir ein bisschen mehr zu tun weil wir ja
die neuen Öle erstmal probeweise fahren
auch bei uns in einer kleinen
haben um zu gucken wie verhält sich das
neue Öl und so ja erstmal haben wir ein
bisschen mehr zu tun und dann schauen
wir mal mich wurmt eben dass das ja über
eine gewisse Ideologie hier
Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr gebracht werden
und im Prinzip auch die Versorgung der
ganzen Region fast 60 Jahre hat die
Raffinerie russisches Erdöl verarbeitet
ab Neujahr wird PCK auf anderen Wegen
beliefert
die Raffinerie wird ab Januar über
Rostock versorgt da sind die Schiffe
bestellt und zusätzliche Mengen kommen
über Polen so dass wir auch im Januar
von einer Auslastung von 70 Prozent
ausgehen und die werden im Laufe des
Jahres dann weiter erhöhen wollen
Tankschiffe vor allem aus Übersee
sichern über den Hafen von Rostock und
eine Pipeline immerhin 55% des
rohölbedarfs der Raffinerie Polen
liefert ab Jahresbeginn aus Danzig 15%.
weitere 15% könnten hinzukommen wenn
Kasachstan Öl durch die duschvorleitung
quer durch Russland liefert russisches
Erdöl auf einen Schlag komplett zu
ersetzen das ist aus Sicht von Experten
ein riskanter Plan es ist unklar ob wir
mit dem Verzicht auf russisches Pipeline
Öl
mehr russlandschaden oder uns selbst
mehr Schaden dadurch dass nicht genügend
Benzin und Diesel in Ostdeutschland
produziert werden kann dadurch dass
möglicherweise
Kurzarbeit in der Raffinerie Schwedt
entsteht Jens Köppen war Lehrling in der
Raffinerie schon damals hieß es wenn das
PCK husted hat die Stadt Grippe nun
sitzt er für die Region im Bundestag und
fürchtet dass der Großbetrieb den
abrupten die verstopft nicht verkraftet
wir brauchen eine unbedingte
Verschiebung mindestens um ein halbes
Jahr und dann zu sehen wie es weitergeht
aber wenn PCK überleben will brauchen
wir weiterhin
vollständigen Ersatz bzw vollständige
Lieferung über die Durchwahl doch das
lehnt die Bundesregierung ab bis Ende
Januar sind Lieferverträge für nicht
russisches Öl schon fest vereinbart eine
ganze Stadt hofft dass es auch darüber
hinaus eine Zukunft für Schwedt gibt
ursprünglich da gab es Wärmestuben in
Burgen oder in Klöstern weil das
Beheizen aller Räume früher technisch
noch nicht machbar war in Großbritannien
werden nun wieder Wärmestuben besucht
weil den Menschen schlicht das Geld
fehlt zum Heizen das Land leidet von
allen G7 Staaten am schwersten an den
Folgen der Pandemie und der Energiekrise
und auch der brexit Macht zu schaffen
Rezession Inflation und echte Armut
Andreas Stamm führt uns durch die
heutigen streets of London und darüber
hinaus
er hat 40 Jahre geschuftet nun ist zu
chasarota Rentner und kann es nicht
fassen dass er hier gelandet ist in
einer Wärmestube im Mittel englischen
Vulva Hemden irgendwie sei er immer über
die Runden gekommen bis die Preise für
Gas Strom Lebensmittel förmlich
explodiert sind
wenn ich hier bin kann ich zu Hause die
Heizung für einige Stunden ausmachen das
spart viel Geld dann wieder an und
überhaupt kann ich nur einen Raum heizen
die Wärmestube eröffnet Ende Oktober
gleichzeitig eine Tafel für alle die
sich sonst entscheiden müssten zwischen
essen oder heizen
grundnahrungsmittel sind gut ein Drittel
teurer als im vergangenen Winter Gas und
Stromkosten doppelt so viel trotz
staatlicher Hilfen und preisdeckel doch
selbst das Personal der
Hilfsorganisation ist froh hier zu sein
erklärt die Leiterin
und zu Hause gilt auch für mich heizen
oder essen dabei verdiene ich relativ
okay es betrifft nicht nur diejenigen
die Sozialleistungen bekommen es
betrifft eigentlich alle wir sollten
schämen dass ein reiches Land wir sind
ja kein Entwicklungsland sich darauf
zurückzieht Wärmestuben zu eröffnen
in der Stadt seines aktuell gut 40
Stuben bis zu 100 könnten es Ende des
Winters sein ergänzt Story jetzt wo es
richtig kalt wird nicht nur ein Phänomen
in Wolverhampton wie die Karte der
Hilfsorganisation Worms spaces zeigt
3.500 sind es in ganz Großbritannien
wollen den Albtraum aus Krisen seit dem
Finanzmarkt Crash 2008 dann der brexit
die Pandemie der Ukraine Krieg der die
Lebenshaltungskosten nochmal nach oben
treiben die Löhne und Produktivität
dagegen stagnieren seit 14 Jahren die
Folge sind 14,5 Millionen Briten jeder
Fünfte der in Armut lebt
nicht die Wirtschaft wachse im Land
sondern die Zahl der Tafeln Galgen Humor
an der Grundschule in Games Bro in
Zahlen fürs Land heißt das vor zehn
Jahren nutzen 60.000 Briten eine Tafel
jetzt
Millionen bei der wöchentlichen
Essensausgabe an Eltern an der Schule
heißt das lange Schlangen die seit
Wochen noch länger werden
frisches Obst und Gemüse andere
Grundnahrungsmittel mir und vielen fehlt
einfach das Geld dafür
1000 Kilo Lebensmittel in 20 Minuten weg
meist bevor die letzten dran kommen auch
weil sie niemand wegschicken so die
Schulleiterin
in letzter Zeit stellen wir fest dass
die Leute jedes Mal mehr mitnehmen und
es kommen auch immer mehr die keine
Kinder an der Schule haben
in der Wärmestube in Wolverhampton
erklären die meisten Gasi sein Helfer
nicht Nutzer die Scham darüber nicht für
sich selbst sorgen zu können das
vielleicht bedrückendste an diesem Tag
und nun geht es weiter mit eigentlich
recht zuversichtlichen
Wirtschaftsnachrichten oder Hanna ja und
zwar mit einer positiven Meldung von der
gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung diese
erwartet zum Jahresende ein deutliches
Plus von 2,1 Milliarden Euro und das
obwohl noch vor einem Jahr mit einem
kräftigen Minus von 6,5 Milliarden Euro
gerechnet wurde weil rehhalla in
Frankfurt wie lässt sich dieser
unerwartete Überschuss erklären also das
liegt vor allem am Arbeitsmarkt der
trotz der Krise stabil geblieben ist
dadurch konnten mehr Menschen als
erwartet in die Rentenkasse einzahlen
auch war durch Corona die Sterblichkeit
der älteren höher noch ist die
Rentenkasse gut gefüllt aber eines ist
auch klar die gesetzliche
Rentenversicherung ist ein
Zuschussgeschäft ohne staatliche Hilfe
trägt sich das System nicht schon jetzt
fließen pro Jahr über 100 Milliarden
Euro aus der Bundes aus dem
Bundeshaushalt an die Rentenkasse das
heißt trotz positiver Jahresbilanz
bleibt
genau die strukturellen Probleme die
bleiben ja der demografische Wandel
schon jetzt gibt es deutlich weniger
Berufseinsteiger als neue Ruheständler
das heißt weniger Arbeitnehmer müssen
mit ihren Beiträgen die Bezüge von mehr
Rentnern stemmen und die Herausforderung
wird in den kommenden Jahren noch größer
nämlich dann wenn immer mehr Babyboomer
in Rente gehen kommendes Jahr möchte die
Bundesregierung eine Reform vorlegen
aber da ist sich die Ampel noch sehr
sehr uneinig wie sie das System fit für
die Zukunft machen will das Rentenalter
soll laut Koalitionsvertrag aber nicht
steigen vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einschätzung
und jetzt die Lottozahlen von diesem
Mittwoch lauten 4 14 17 27 29 42
Superzahl 3 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
morgen startet die für schanzentournee
in Oberstdorf heute fand die
Qualifikation für das Auftaktspringen
statt mit dem Ergebnis dass alle sieben
deutschen Skispringer dabei sein werden
bester Deutscher wurde Karl Geiger mit
Rang 7
der Lokalmatador von Oberstdorf Karl
Geiger zeigt vor 16.000 begeisterten
Zuschauern einen soliden Sprung auf
129einhalb Meter ich schau dass sie
wirklich jedem Sprunger Stückel besser
wäre das wäre das Ziel und dann am Ende
wird abgerechnet ebenfalls in guter Form
präsentiert sich Andreas Wellinger als
Achter mit einer Weite von 130 Metern
insgesamt qualifizieren sich alle sieben
deutschen Springer für den Wettkampf
morgen ganz vorne aber heute der
Norweger
er landet bei 133 einhalb Metern der
Weltcup Gesamtführende und top Favorit
aus Polen David Kubatzki
im Lokaljournalismus da gibt es einen
Grundsatz der unter die Haut geht das
Wichtigste auf der Welt geschieht dort
wo du lebst aber was machen die Menschen
die dort wo sie nun Leben kein Wort
verstehen die aus ihrer Heimat geflohen
sind und nun in Hamburg Berlin oder
Frankfurt das wichtigste mitbekommen
wollen was in ihrer neuen Welt geschieht
Deutsch lernen klar aber bis dahin und
viele wollen ja gar nicht auf Dauer
bleiben viele aus der Ukraine haben
Hoffnung zurückzukehren und andere
hoffen zu bleiben
amal heißt Hoffnung auf Arabisch amal
heißt die Online-Plattform für
Lokalnachrichten über die Stefanie
gagusch berichtet
auf Recherche in Berlin Nana morosovo
besucht ukrainische Flüchtlinge
Olga und Olga Mutter und Tochter
strandeten vor vier Monaten hier der
Sohn und Enkel an der Front und der
Tränen erzählen sie
und jetzt wolltest du wir wünschen uns
dass unsere Soldaten nach Hause kommen
zu ihren Familien wir wünschen uns so
sehr Frieden für unsere Heimat
die ukrainische Journalistin schreibt
ihre Geschichte auf veröffentlicht sie
später online vor dem Krieg Management L
the big challenge for me personally das
ist eine große Herausforderung für mich
persönlich hier aber wir alle sind
bereits zu arbeiten weiterzumachen das
hier ist unsere Front unser Widerstand
Nanas Bericht erscheint bei amal
übersetzt Hoffnung eigentlich ein
tägliches Online-Magazin in arabischen
farsi seit Anfang 2022 gibt es aber auch
die ukrainische Redaktion weiß ich die
Schicksale aller hier so ähneln das war
als der Krieg in der Ukraine losgegangen
ist dass bei uns im Team gerade im
syrischen Team aber auch von den
Kollegen und Kolleginnen aus Afghanistan
viele gesagt haben da sind so viele
Sachen die sie daran erinnern was damals
in ihren Ländern auch passiert ist von
dem Methoden dass dann viele gesagt
haben kommen wir brauchen jetzt auch
einmal auf Ukrainisch finanziert wird er
mal von der evangelischen Kirche und
Stiftungen sie geben den geflohenen
Journalistinnen und Journalisten Arbeit
und eine Stimme ihre Waffe für die
Freiheit majam
kommt aus dem Iran
I can right hier kann ich schreiben
meine Worte gebrauchen dass iranische
Regime fürchtet sich vor Worten und ich
bin sicher dass Journalisten mit ihrem
Job helfen können im Kampf gegen dieses
Regime im fighting Gas
2015 als Flüchtling aus Syrien er
arbeitet seit sechs Jahren bei mal
seitdem haben sich die Themen in seiner
Community verändert
zum Beispiel am 1 waren wir haben wir
über Sprachkurs geredet über wohnsuche
Wohnung suchen geredet über Führerschein
geredet und danach zum Beispiel letzte
Jahre wir haben über die Politik und
Wahlen geredet heute recherchierte er
mit einem Kollegen bei Geschäftsleuten
zum Thema Energie
der gebürtige Syrer will in Deutschland
bleiben hat hier eine Heimat gefunden
und kann wie alle bei amal seine
Geschichten frei erzählen
so das war's von uns morgen machen hier
Marietta Slomka und Hanna Zimmermann
weiter ja und wir empfehlen Ihnen noch
unser heute journal Update gegen 0 Uhr
mit nasam göktem
[Musik]
guten Abend das Hoch Leonard steht
stellvertretend für hohen Luftdruck im
Südosten und Süden Europas in Nord
Mittel und Westeuropa dagegen dominieren
die Tiefs das Tief Kerstin bringt morgen
stürmische Mühlen an der Nordsee und sie
dann weiter nordwärts und wird ersetzt
durch das nächste Tief Lady heute Nacht
also regnet es oft in Deutschland und
nur hier in Sachsen und in Bayern es ist
zum Teil trocken oder auch klar in
Niederbayern dort singen dann die
Temperaturen in den leichten frostominus
zwei Grad sonst gehen die Temperaturen
in Bayern auf 3 bis 0 Grad runter im
übrigen Deutschland auf 10 bis 6 Grad
die ist Temperaturen morgen liegen im
östlichen Bayern bei sechs sonst geht's
aber auf 9 bis 14 Grad drauf und auch
morgen regnet es ganz verbreitet es gibt
auch kräftige Schauer im Westen am
ehesten trocken bleibt das ganz im Osten
und im Südosten Deutschlands bei Süd
Ostwind und aus Südwesten wird es jetzt
immer wärmer sie sehen wie sich die
Wärme hier von den Kanarischen Inseln
auf den Weg zu uns Macht über die
iberische Halbinsel also Spanien und
Portugal und Frankreich bis zu uns nach
Mitteleuropa strömt und das hält auch
noch im neuen Jahr 2023 an am Wetter
ändert sich am Freitag erstmal wenig am
Silvestertag aber wird es hier in
Norddeutschland richtig stürmisch und am
Oberrhein könnte es vielleicht sogar mal
für 20 Grad reichen und ähnlich mild wie
das alte Jahr aufhört beginnt auch das
neue bis bald